the americans in turn responded with a
fairly
anti-european sentiment you know
particularly against the french but
um donald rumsfeld was one of their you
know
uh face faces of the administration said
that uh he didn't want to deal with old
europe he was far more interested in new
europe
now he was talking about when france and
germany voted against the war
so he wasn't interested in old europe
he's talking about two ancient
civilizations he was interested in new
europe and when he's in new york
he meant places like scrovovia vivonia
places where tractors are ministers
and people sit down to a dinner of
boiled radiators
places that are not that swish really
who are going to do whatever america
says
because they're hoping one day to see a
photograph of a pot of jam
and no no
but in particular in particular they
were very very
anti-french you know they built on this
whole image of the weak
cheese eating surrender monkeys was the
phrase
which is kind of good you know
but that entirely plugged into this
image of the weak
sensual pleasure-loving french you know
not going to war because they're all
still in bed
at two in the afternoon with the sheets
coiled about their knees
lying there scratching themselves
smoking your galways inside as you turn
sweating neat sansaire
before one of them sloughs off the
sheets to pad around the kitchen
naked no not naked naked from the waist
down
to emphasize their nakedity
picking up yesterday's croissant crumbs
with their sweaty feet
slashing yesterday's paintings
what was i thinking
it's lacking rubbish
[Applause]
oh my god i can't believe it it's off i
ate my paintings i ate them i ate your
paintings too
you ate my paintings no i hate them why
do we have to talk [ __ ] english
your work is so delivered there because
you can't be mine
and mine is [ __ ] to begin with
i'm so bored in this atelier
stop it stop slashing things
get something for breakfast i'm starving
there's nothing we have nothing we're
poor
let's make love again instead of eating
knows the things you do to me
i'm so sorry
even my toenails leave me alone
come on you know you want to eat
no get me something to eat before i die
there's nothing here i told you except
chocolate bread
where are you from exactly by the way
i don't know i'm euro trash shut up
catching up a little bit about the the
family and how are the kids sir
well zachary got married he's uh 25 he
got married to a lovely lady good
and and she has uh passports for france
too which is always great to have for
him you know to be able to go to france
just because at any moment you know to
go whenever you feel really good about
yourself go to paris and go you're not
that great
um it was fun and uh
and uh and michael phelps
wasn't it i guess it's amazing too
wearing that full body condom you know
that
what it was that you know that lovely
that skin tight suit you go oh you're
jewish it's like
that lovely my favorite moment though is
when the american relay team
beat the french relay team that had been
talking doing talk a little trash
you go we are going to bury you it's a
pool you can't bury them we are going to
do badly to you huh
and they beat them by a 1 100th of a
second and the next thing they cut to
the french by the side the pool going
okay things happen you know
[Applause]
it's crazy what are you doing
crazy oh great way to go michael swim
fast
you eat more than a small african
village go go
actually smoking at poolside yes looking
at
oh you have to race now hold on i'm
ready
one time these french people asked me
for directions in new york and the best
part was they didn't even they just
asked totally in french
they didn't make there was no hesitation
at all
they didn't even go like a how do you
say or something like that nothing
they just walk up to me and one of them
just goes
i was like i don't speak french
and the guy couldn't imagine what might
be going wrong he's like
i was like guess what i don't speak
french which isn't weird because we're
not in france right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh man i tell you what
we invented so
there you go lingerie lingerie all right
how can you prove that do you have like
an orville wilbur right
a picture of the first three
he's called lawad middle g and i also
brought michael jackson's uh chef
uh you used to cook for michael jackson
yeah just cook for madonna brad pitt
you know bradley snow peas credited her
with ch
it's not angie jolie who he credits for
changing his life it was her
she cooked for him she got him in shape
for troy she was his personal chef oh
yeah
that's true and you know i brought her
here because hopefully
in that moment she's single and
hopefully she's going to leave the
studio not single so
and get you all in so we're all looking
we're all looking at anthony here
anthony we're taking home michael
jackson's uh ex-chef and she's canadian
to boot
mj's ex-chef in the last few months of
his life
is from montreal wow wow and he was
looking so healthy towards the end as
well
yeah that's great for your resume it's
from
the great cooking yeah that's really
good for your resume
i really want to be credited exactly
yeah leave that off
did you ever see him with the nose off
like just the whole
the nose and like did you ever see just
the heart that's a great question like
you know when you wake up and you
haven't done your hair did he ever walk
out without a nose
i never saw that no but you know it did
snap off right didn't it
i heard that rumor yes that's why they
couldn't resuscitate him properly
you have to pinch the nose
oh man oh come on what's up jim
that's fine he's a little gruff though
you know he's there's a language barrier
here you just
yeah just listen well you know this is
no no's you don't
press uh oh man oh the french guy is not
happy with that french
wait a minute i always think the french
even when they speak in french
seem like they don't know their own
language they're always they're always
halfway through a word and then they're
like
i tell you it's all in the smell it's
all in the smell you you don't know
if you don't have the scent of the woman
ah yeah
okay here the americans act like they're
the only ones who [ __ ] chicks
you go in there and it's like walking in
a hospital
i'm sorry it does not turn me on voila
thank you oh so you like a little bit of
dirt and a little bit napoleon used to
write to josephine saying i'll be home
in three days from war
please don't wash oh really
[Laughter]
napoleon was like there gary coleman
[Laughter]
he was so he was so short he just came
up to her knees
this microphone that's coming in from
lou in new york lou
yeah what's up guys hey real fast uh
french guy um it sounds like your accent
kind of gets stronger and weaker as
uh as you're talking where you actually
from oh [ __ ] you're faking
i am from you know where the other side
yeah yeah so this is
where are you from where are you from
i'm from paris paris
oh jesus uh now i'm from i'm from
they don't say parents they say perry
you're from rhode island
yeah brooklyn new york
why do you think he's faking it why
little quick he uses little words like i
have a degree in linguistics i listen to
that kind of stuff but little work that
he says
he changes the way that he says them
different times like little words like
the words ah
um sometimes they are in the front like
that it changes
that yes you have good deals huh yeah
what do you do
i guarantee you're fake right guarantee
it yeah i know you might be french you
might be from france talk about paris
what are some of your favorite things
about paris the eye for the club
what street do you live on in paris no
no i live in main street
i grew up in pigal which is the you know
yeah
and that's where i grew up it's great i
actually love that area
when did you when did you move away from
france how many years ago 10 years
so you've only spoken english for ten
years i speak no i speak a lot of
different languages
people can learn english at school
europeans can all speak english before
they move out that's not he has
he has an accent from like all right we
are all disagreeing with your term speak
some friends
just give us a bit casamela in french
because that's this guy i lived in
london too
say some dirty words in french
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh yeah you just [ __ ] put
some french on your ass big boy
that was hey nazi come in we'll cook for
you
anything you need
oh
like they're like they're like nasa they
started off good
yeah that's just sort of petered out
it's an imaginal line
you really did that line stunk that
thing
stunk germans got behind that you didn't
even have your backs covered
no they
with no defense to the rear of it so if
they ever got an enemy
coming in on their rear they're done for
us that's going to happen again
they will never be able to go through
the outdance
really it's true they get a little uh
kakia but yeah a little cocky
do you find french canadians just to be
[ __ ] dicks
like whenever i'm in like montreal i'm
just like this is the most useless
[ __ ] thing i've ever seen like what
are people speaking
french in canada for yeah
yeah yeah you know andy norman uh no
just poor readers
because it's all just believing because
you look like a god
you look like a guy who falls asleep in
the strip club
yeah you look like a guy who's very
perceptive
that's just who i am what do you think
of those dances there
i tell you what about i tell you
montreal best strippers in the world
it's like
the great looking strippers plus you're
allowed to touch them all you want
but i came i came from a culture where
you couldn't touch a strip you'd get
kicked in the head right
and so uh the first time i had a girl in
montreal give me a lap dance and then
she kept on pulling my hands up to touch
her i thought
she was into me so
[Laughter]
did you ever bang a montreal stripper i
i have done yes
i have once but i've i've been there a
few times how long did
how how long did it last uh i was drunk
i couldn't tell you how long did it
start
all right come on be nice don't don't be
mean to what happened you were in bed
your head was in bed with jack what's
what happened
how was it last night utah i'm trying to
behave i can't
you tell me no no you you're much better
whatever you say i complain well
it started you were on your back and
sleeping
and then i came in from the
island brooklyn
i turned you over and that's when you
woke up oh you
you go group french goes greek and you
said something like this oh
damn he's implying that you had his
penis in your mouth yeah
that's actually your [ __ ] blair's
cousin jerry from the sense of life
thank god yes just for you
ah say oh yes well musky smells like i
don't
like a stinky vagina i like a nice
showered washed out one
yeah you you chicken no no
you didn't grow up in australia with the
blazing heat
have you seen a girl who's laid on the
beach for five days with the sun pelting
down on it
that's one must kill in cold weather
it's okay but not in the heat
they've got to wash off i don't like a
tart tasting vagina like you're looking
at battery tips
yes yes they say the best [ __ ] per
capita
is in norway they really deserved a
bigger life
scandinavian pussy's the best looking
[ __ ]
butter [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i tell you what that you go to sweden
and do a gig
and it's just you you go with mcdonald's
and it's like [ __ ]
claudia schiffer's just their service
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous you've
been there too
ridiculous how hot the women are it's
not just a rumor
it's like they're killing all the ugly
people but they were the last
if you go outside of stockholm that's
where they keep all their brunettes and
ugly people they're like
they make them go to the mountains you
know the swedes were the last people to
give up on eugenics they were
sterilizing the disabled in the 80s oh
jesus
you know in the 80s in the 80s i was
seeing down syndrome
people going get me a hammer for these
testicles
[Laughter]
they weren't killing them
they were doing hitler's work is it safe
to say i'm the only guy in this
[ __ ] studio who's hit the home
run
norway sweden finland denmark
mate i'd gigged in europe for a while i
[ __ ] everyone in all those countries
is yeah yeah that's what he's saying
we've done it luxembourg what about
paying customers what about
luxembourg i've [ __ ] all over europe
yeah this is the second time he's tried
to top him and he hasn't been able to i
know he's going
for two when was the last time you got
laid you look so frustrated when that's
don't get laid
actually i can't talk about this anymore
last time i came into the show
yeah yeah yeah i gotta keep my mouth
shut
who didn't get laid here last night
because it i didn't get laid last night
i think the rest of the studio dude it's
a
bit
it's quite here today i think most of us
did it no
yeah what happened why is that safe to
say here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not trying to top you i just have
been lucky now he's trying to top you
that's what i'm liking you [ __ ]
swatted it back twice
a stripper well yeah yeah is it safe to
say i'm the only one who hit the home
run
actually i came up and [ __ ] uh back
to back in all those
places have you been to luxembourg he's
reaching for straws
there were six norwegian producers at
the premiere last night because i'm
pitching a film i'm planning on doing
the film
his highness and anthony do norway i
want to take
anthony on a road trip i like more
weenies
and you should go to norway with uh uh
doctor hello ian halpern
do you want to do some tv i mean you
look better on radio but do you want it
do you want to make it live
you got to give them that one that's a
good one you don't want it yeah yeah
i think we'd be a great team i mean we
used the spar man what are we going to
spar
like i will rent out madison square
garden and go one on one with you
in boxing why do you want to box anthony
what is he talking
about i don't think i fight i just shoot
people if they [ __ ] with me
[Laughter]
would
that's the answer